[Music]
foreign
it's Heist time
bye you get a head start on Heist prep
good luck I'm already dressed well I'm
also dressed and I made breakfast wait
where are my eggs in my belly
now get a move on it's Heist time I love
Halloween
sorry Sarge
oh Halloween is the worst
everyone's drunk wearing a mask and
carrying a fake gun plus all the girls
think they have to dress sexy I know
that is the worst please make them stop
I passed a [ __ ] Tree on the way here
who wants to have sex with a tree was it
a maple was it a maple
buongiorno Bongiorno pretty cool stoom
huh stem short for costume ah all right
let me guess you are dumpy Chuck Norris
no don't be Ron Weasley no guys stop it
he put thought into his costume and he
is obviously Miranda from Sex in the
City guys I'm Mario Batali Malto Mario
is he also a homeless troll doll because
he look like a homeless troll doll a
sweet potato costume dude thank you
there's a man with impeccable taste he
bit a guy's butt off at a WNBA game
Eric Stoltz for mask I'll take it yeah
good morning boy it's Halloween
I'm surprised you didn't put on a
costume I was going to sir but then I
decided screw that jazz
well I'm the only one who ever dresses
up no one ever gets my costume and they
make fun of me so I'm done
these people don't deserve my dress-up
gifts
Charles
seriously no costume what the hell
Charles where's your Halloween spirit
but you guys always make fun of me I
have never once insulted you in my life
especially vis-a-vis your appearance
yeah man we always love your costumes
remember last year when you came as that
person and or thing yes I do remember
sure permission is Sprint to my car get
my emergency costume does it matter if I
say no no
[Music]
Bam Bam Boom
what the what why are you dressed up you
look like an idiot but uh but yeah what
are you supposed to be a sassy car
mechanic no come on he's clearly the
rejected Pop-Tarts mascot Harry pop tart
I am not you know who I am Squad that's
enough you're making boil for bad on
purpose he's Elvis yes Elvis stoico the
Canadian figure skater no
no okay parties around the corner
tipster said there will be a huge amount
of drug activity
costumes
so smell Department never washes them so
it's probably vomit hey
I got you chocolate yet another great
thing about Halloween chocolate thanks
oh look Raggedy Ann is drinking vodka
right from the bottle people think if
they put on a costume they can just get
away with anything they want
Halloween is Christmas for jerks come on
ma'am no open containers
um why should I listen to you bone
person it's called a skeleton it's a
very common word just put the Vodka away
you guys are cops these guys are cops
attention boys and ghouls nope every
Halloween I dress up in an amazing
costume and you never get what I am no
we get what you are an adult man who
enjoys dress up very funny Rosa this
year that won't be a problem because
you're gonna pick my costume ah come on
uh Miss Pac-Man's nipple no that's brown
why would you know that to be on not to
be not to be thank you
ah Joan of Arc Rod Stewart Martha
Stewart He-Man Master of the Universe
I've got it Gay Robin Hood
yes
you look like such a cop come on have
some fun you know
to help you blend it
stop trying to get me to love Halloween
it'll never work I'm backing it up oh
God please don't
hey heads up I'll cut him off at the
exit okay
to drop some on it
oh [ __ ] everything is sticking to me oh
okay uh
what is that how is it hot and cold
handmaid's tale this is Amy she won't
shut up about how relevant that show is
in today's political landscape it's
relevant as hell but I'm not doing
anything
Terry also loved the show this is him no
no I love Elizabeth Moss Terry thought
the show was too Bleak they're coming
from everywhere hello blessed be the
proof baby yes copy watch that show
watch what that's my pickup line what
are they doing I haven't heard from
Charles we need to check to make sure
everything check what the server I stole
the cumberbund from under there an hour
ago you knew about are you playing the
server I've known about your plans for
weeks oh they're circling
up
hello of Amy hmm
I don't know what's going on I do
handmaid's out
they really listen to you
what is all this no I think Halloween is
for jerks well this Halloween I was the
jerk
I'm sorry about tonight I'm sorry about
tonight we found the title for
Santiago's follow-up sex tape I'm sorry
I couldn't convince you to love
Halloween it's not your fault I was
terrible it's not your fault I was
terrible is also one of your sex tapes
Halloween is bearable
but
don't okay anyway we're all going to the
bars so get changed because you can't be
the only one there not wearing a steam a
doom oh my God caught on no no
you betrayed me but why I can't have
more of these trophies in our home the
cumberbund was already in the living
room what's next a rusty medical
bracelet suspended above our bed yes now
hand it over I don't have it I gave it
to Amy son ago you betrayed me as well
you betrayed me first you were working
with Rosa this whole time it wasn't real
I was always gonna stab her in the back
you were what kind of person treats
another human being like that
and then you ship me to New Jersey first
of all grow up second of all how'd you
get back here so fast if you get a box
wet enough it's very easy to bust out of
it no one asked any follow-ups I knew I
couldn't trust you Rosa that's why I was
gonna double cross you with Bill that's
right he didn't really die hey guys if
you really thought I'd missed this
year's Heist no way I'm part of the
squad okay this is officially getting
too hard to track who has the bracelet
now Santiago yeah and none of you are
getting it we'll see about that
remember that very fancy Swiss pan I got
you for Christmas the one that you keep
in your pocket at all times it's a taser
bro
yeah Amy do not make me taste you again
what I just turned out it's a girl oh my
God oh my God it's happening quick
someone get a reaction video of me
becoming an uncle ah she's making it up
the pregnancy scan was my idea no no no
no no Amy wait is that true did you just
lie to me about our baby did you let us
about our baby first
um
salutations captain
I was wondering per chance if you would
like to attend the Opera with me this
Eve I'll pass choosing instead to stay
in my locked office with my watch still
safely on my wrist I had a feeling you
might say that thus far I've decided to
bring the Opera to you
Hitchcock Scully
now Hammer It's Time It's hammer time
you're up dagger
okay Boyle and only because you insisted
I say this it's time to drop a deuce
now the chicken baby
whoa come on Amy not cool that's a guy
Peralta that's enough
all right